шеннон і кулер сидячи
за галію поважаючого шкірного ти ж не
треба підніматися харчування там ще
c
сідай на для України щоб ми
поважали
що ми допоможемо горова треба довести ціль
на ось особи його ось на тему харчування шум
особливо
наріман філія за 1 сезон на спец блоки
і
знає і ось вся банда аксьонова під
прикриттям путіна за раз пачино я нову
хмелю беруть би проти кримсько-татарського
народу за етнічною ознакою ми моєму
сьогодні знаки того, що всі кримські
татари за раз будуть ланкою вашої то сяк
народ як народ не ok гуни поважають народ
терористам тому
наші наші обидві візи за раз такі механізми
за проводить і щоб не так ти можеш
вивести ось чат і цій банді зводити
рахунки з кримськими татарами
ми 23 цирк мене прийняли до парламенту та
дуже важлива постанова
сказав ще б починаємо вуст варівати між
парламент та час кримської платформи на
шкода кримська платформа 20 за раз не
вийшло з'їденою такою заявою і проти де
окупантів криму так давайте ми будемо у
роботи такі як рокки які будуть
вимушувати змушувати з їх наших
учасників кримської платформи примати
болю вирішив che di проти окупанта дякую
диякон чиновника